hey what's up guys and welcome to a
let's play of the eldon ring network
test my name is dave klein aka dave
control
and let's jump into it
so this is the final of the network test
times i'm going to go ahead and play as
the warrior class i feel like a lot of
people i'm doing bloody wolf which is
fun because so berserk-esque but
i like my my dex style stuff you know
i'll probably switch to a bloody wolf
style uh
weapon later on a heavier weapon
especially for some of these enemies in
this game so
um for those of you who don't know me
i've been covering and talking about
souls games for
a long time at this point like eight
years on my main channel
um
done plenty of lore videos and all that
i'm gonna skip the tutorial section
which is down there and just try to jump
into the meat of what i can show because
i only have three hours as this is the
final one i didn't get into the uh early
network tests that some other souls guys
did
uh and some other outlets people did so
um i didn't have quite as much time with
the game
and three a.m to six a.m which was some
of the times pst which is where i live
is pretty rough but
uh let's find some fun things to talk
about society graces right here are the
new version of bonfires in the game
and something interesting about the game
that i've noticed that has been
affecting me quite a bit is that there's
no kick or bash to
make an enemy kind of like stutter so
you can get in there and attack for
shielded enemies
uh it seems like they've kind of
replaced that with this new critical
strike that you can do
to hit enemies off guard
but it's a little more of a risk to it
so
um yeah that's kind of the balance it
seems like they found but here we are in
limb grave
and honestly i really like the graphics
of this game i know that it's a bit of a
uh back and forth for how people feel i
guess some people like it some people
said it's not as good as demon souls but
this game was made for
the ps4 and xbox one so i think it's
pretty understandable
that you know demon souls was made by a
third party company demon souls i mean
the remaster
which all they did was focus on making
the making the graphics look better i'm
gonna go ahead and skip talking to this
person because they don't have much
interest to say interesting things to
say
normally when i do let's plays of souls
games and all that or securo or whatever
i like to really deep dive into the lore
of the games
but
because i don't know too much yet even
though i've been trying to read and look
into the item descriptions that are in
this game
i don't feel comfortable like i just
feel like there's not enough for me to
really say or no
new to the game as this is now open
world
are the wandering animals that you see
which you can kill for materials
same with materials like this that you
can grab to craft
there is a boss right there that i'm not
going to engage in because i tried
actually this i kind of ruined my first
time with the network test just by
trying to kill him i ran naked at him a
bunch of times just to try to learn the
dodge timing and everything
and uh
it was not a good time
okay so this is going to be my third
side of grace i think that means we're
going to meet uh melinda
i'm pretty sure that the third one
is wait
is this my oh this is my second one
outside sorry the fourth one is going to
be
uh once you activate it though you can
fast travel
right at the start there are points
where your map is deactivated in legacy
dungeons which i think is worth noting
we find our first smith right here and
smithing stone shards so we can work on
upgrading our weapons
also when i'm two-handing like this by
the way oh the l2 is still that but like
l1
is slashing both of the swords i
honestly haven't tried two-handing other
uh weapons yet to be honest i've just
been doing it with the swords i don't
have any uh any equip any anything yet
really so i don't think i'll be able to
buy crap unfortunately
from kale over here
yeah but
the one thing he sells you that's
interesting is the way for you to craft
items together which is all the stuff
that you gather
another thing that's new in this is the
sites of grace now have ways for you to
go in directions which in an open world
game like this kind of makes sense
uh you know what i'm actually gonna go
yeah oh you know what i should show you
guys this kind of cool actually that i
found
and i noticed because this only
activates before you go to the dungeons
i realize
so this wonderful statue right here you
can actually examine and interact with
it
hello
guide and gatekeeper for those
journeying back to the tree and she
gives you her own signal of where to go
and that's actually going to be a
dungeon
and there's another one i found but it
was after i had already finished all the
dungeons because i went ahead i played
this just on my own for fun
and uh
beat all the bosses all of them and now
and then kind of goofed around a bit
doing some pvp and uh
trying to play around with some of the
weapons and getting footage of that
because i
don't know where this is going up but if
it's on game spot if not game spot i
work for game spot so um
the footage i also was like trying to
get for them so i could have a run at
every single boss
um and try to like do some weapon
showcase stuff in case we want to use
that
although i i'm such i i'm not a big
magic user in any of these games so i
didn't get too much magic unfortunately
and uh here we go
our first dungeon the stormfoot
catacombs i don't remember which one
this is
so hopefully it goes well uh oh
melon is not here so uh
hopefully this really goes well because
i can't level up yet so uh
hopefully i'm not screwing myself over
oh you know what i want is my buckler
because
yeah i knew there'd be someone who'd
come and
attack me but
all right
excuse me excuse me i gotta i got some
crap to do oh i didn't uh swish my tears
around sorry i'm just gonna go into this
room and grab that item first
yeah i knew someone was gonna ambush me
but i got distracted because
my dog started howling or something
outside
not a good excuse but i'm going with it
tarnish blossom it's a crafting material
if i remember correctly
uh and
i'm gonna try to look at some of the
item descriptions of some of the more
interesting things i would do a little
bit more of this normally looking and
reading all the item descriptions but
since i don't have that much time as i'm
very specifically only have three hours
uh i'm going to do a little bit less of
item description reading and like i said
because i don't know what a lot of it is
yet unfortunately and i'd like to get to
some of the juicy stuff for you guys
i like all the bosses and dungeons and
all that so
uh hopefully i can be a decent tour
guide through the network test and talk
about some different mechanics
uh this right here is new the cookbook a
but also this
so
basically what this is is a summoning
pool where people uh their signs get
placed automatically if you want to make
it easier to summon
for
near bosses and all that
uh okay so we're oh wait is i think i
remember which dungeon this is
hi
yes oh no they both came down get out of
here crap
it's not that they're difficult they're
just fast and i didn't want to get
ganked by them
one two three oh crap that was my what i
was worried about
nope
could start me
good start
i'm gonna fast cut this
all right let's try that again uh all
right so we got this bro who's gonna
jump down for sure the other one's gonna
shoot at me from above but
all right now we're there much easier
much better
oh yeah also you can see
no i'm sorry my
one of my dogs is jumping up in front of
recording stuff and i don't want her to
mess up the cables
so
there we go one of the things shelby
all right so
thank you shelby
and no i don't feel good about running
across right now and i'm sneaking by
accident too which is not gonna help
all right let's do it no no no screwed
myself over
crap
okay i feel better now about it
yeah because i ran right into the wall
so uh good job me
all right these guys you can actually
pop down by hitting some of them but
oh flame
oh flame
but it doesn't go up to anywhere i've
been trying to explore this stuff it'd
be cool if that was a wall that nobody
found yet
but
yeah i kind of lost track of what i was
gonna say before
all right and through here
yeah nope
nope nope nope
no no
the problem okay so some one of the new
things in the game
is that
now if you want to switch to which
weapon you're holding
i'm just going to take these guys out
long distance
you have to hold triangle and then
choose r1 or
l1 to switch
so it lets you choose which one that you
want to switch pretty easily which is
good so i can hold triangle press l1 to
switch my shield
uh press it to switch to that
to my
weapon in my right hand
so it makes sense but also i've been
noticing that a lot of times when i run
over messages it screws up
that uh element this is a pretty
annoying way
so that's been slightly frustrating
all right got my ashes already i
actually haven't been using the ashes to
fight anyone
but
i'm just realizing how low on health i
am
i gotta start playing better
but yeah it just keeps on being an issue
for me because i switch back and forth
or at least i happen quite a lot
as at the moment i've been using the
shield a little more than i do in souls
probably a lot because i'm still
figuring out the game to a large extent
all right
no
you will not you will not
got it
you know i'm sure there's some back here
too i feel like i just wait they threw
that mist didn't they oh
no
no
no come back this way
i'm not gonna lose this life it's
already embarrassing enough that i died
from like the first mob of enemies oh
yeah i'm done i'm toast
no no no no
crap
this is great this is great all right
i only have the
backup
okay
nope
one two three come on no no no no no no
no no no no
this really should not be intense at all
because these guys are simple but i
really botched the execution here
all right
hopefully i don't die on the fall down
rejected sun rejected
so honestly i've been finding that
uh maybe it's because i haven't played
the games in a little bit but i actually
feel like these games are a little more
challenging
than i found
um
souls
crap
do not do not do not do not do not
do not
i'm so low on health
all right
got the boss door open
and cool
i'm sure some of these are pretending
that there's illusory walls i actually
haven't found an illusory wall as much
as i love
going for that stuff i haven't found one
yet but maybe i
was a little distracted uh for going for
luxury walls because of the time limit
that definitely makes it a lot more
intense trying to
fit things in within the time limit
all right
i know there's a guy down there who i
didn't kill so if i can avoid that and
cool gonna get my sights uh
my tears back
i think that's what it's called the new
flasks
and let's go tackle our first boss shall
we
i remember correctly this one's one i
really enjoyed i thought it was a pretty
cool design
and this is it's funny the dungeon is
really really changing in length these
mini dungeons it's a totally different
feel like it feels like souls in a way
and also doesn't
because of that
oh yeah this guy is so cool i love this
guy the burial tree watch dog oh i'm
glad that you were the one that i fought
first just because you are really cool
just such a fun design
all right and
he's like you think i'm cool eh you
think i'm cool eh
can't believe i botched my dodge
i feel like it's just been a while since
i've done let's play so i'm almost just
a little nervous
there we go
and nope
yep
and
and
[Music]
oh crap
you want to do that now fine
fine we'll go
at a distance now and nope
you may not oh crap
i thought he was gonna like just start
attacking me
honestly like this guy's pretty easy if
you just stay away from him and uh
do some l2s you can see how much more
damage this does too
but you know i wanted to prove that i
could do some iframe dodging
both to you guys and myself i'm a real
boy i swear
i can play a video game
here we go
nope
i guess i gotta
knock him out normally all right
first boss first foe vanquish
and we get another ash of war so the ash
of wars act like uh what you're noticing
me shoot out at the guy was actually an
ash of war and dark souls 3 if you
remember
you had those um
l2 attacks that you could use that were
special sorts of attacks and they were
all very specific to the weapon you had
an elder ring take exactly those
but
some
the weapons still have those but now
there's additional ashes of war that you
can equip which are essentially the same
thing but you can equip on any weapon
and it's going to change the stats of
those weapons and add that 1l2 type of
attack that's like this
so
that's a pretty big change up for eldon
ring that's one of the bigger change-ups
along with
sneaking i guess although i feel like in
big major situations and legacy dungeons
the sneaking hasn't done too much
it was definitely more of a mechanic in
securo i feel like
all right let's take you out i guess
oh another thing i should mention is
that if you take out mobs sometimes
you'll actually get
as you can see vanquishing an enemy
group you'll actually get some tears
back
and a specific type of one depending on
what mob you took out i don't think i
got a string
last time i played on my own
i just got a new weapon how about that
let's get some rune fragments
shall we thanks
and another couple bros down here
i thought there was gonna be an octopus
guy
i guess it's just some of their babies
uh the octopus guy is too
there's like some octopus guys who
aren't too bad because you can just
whack on their head which is what
they're weak too
all right second dungeon let's go
i feel so rushed i like i hate this
three hour time limit thing i feel very
lucky i get to play don't get me wrong
i'm very very lucky about that but
uh i could definitely do without the
three-hour time limit
uh oh you know what i think i am not
very good at this one
is this the double one or is this the
single guy i guess i'll find out in a
moment
this is a single guy never mind okay i
was like i kind of want to level up it's
the one that i'm not that good at
goodbye wolves we'll come back to you
later don't worry don't worry i'll come
back to you guys we gotta we gotta fo to
fight first
a beastman of faram azullah
he's got this sweet cleaver
oh yeah also he actually gets uh stunned
by your attacks so
you know it's like interesting how
different
all these bosses are like these mini
bosses
they're definitely easier than uh say
oh actually i guess this weapon's not
heavy enough to stun him
you know every time i attacked him and i
was stunning stun locking him
or uh
it was like i was using a heavier weapon
so
i guess i'm
playing hard mode now against him
i actually have to remember his patterns
what
i don't want to do that
yeah the bosses here that aren't legacy
dungeon bosses are really really differ
in difficulty
the legacy dungeon bosses single one
that they have here is actually pretty
damn rough
he gave me a not good time
okay this guy is much more difficult now
that i'm not
able to stun lock him he's really easy
with this stun locking oh wait i think
if i remember correctly he's weak to
fire too
nope nope
there we go let me get that backstab in
oh i didn't think he's gonna be able to
hit me
backstab son
yeah yeah i know you're angry i know i
get it
i'd be angry if i were you too
i mean i get it i can heal and you can't
that doesn't seem very fair does it
nope nope
no
all right
all right beast man just you and me
nope
there we go
oh he's got another attack
well really all right i wasn't expecting
that last one there
nope
oh wow that really stuns them huh i
should have been doing that last time
actually
i think i would have beaten him last
time if i had done that
that's okay i could
show playing worse at least i got some
backstabs on him right
all right let me get a backstab
and i'll go back to being a cheese
yeah i feel like we're doing this
against them it's just like
so cheesy
but i guess at the same time it's like
you know
you use fire against them
and it's the same thing you're just kind
of using the strategy that works right
don't worry not every boss you can do
this so if like you're like i need it to
be harder
at least uh
for when i was trying to beat some of
the bosses there was like no way to
choose it that i could tell but maybe i
just didn't know how to do it
properly oh okay
there we go
he's done
[Music]
viridian amber medallion so
this is essentially your version of
rings in this game
and this one's gonna give me more
stamina very nice thank you for the
stamina the other interesting thing that
i get here is going to be this chest
which has this uh wondrous physic
physique
tear um or flask
and
basically this flask
is one where you can choose what's
inside of it with different things that
you get
so it's interesting
you know it's definitely something new
where you can kind of mix and match and
change it up but it works just like an
estus flask it's just like an estus
flask where you can choose your own
uh choose your own adventure
start down down up up down down up up
yeah i just realized that one of my
recordings messed up
so
i've been having so many technical
issues with this when i first tried the
first uh demo which was at 3 am i
actually was like okay i'm waking up for
it i'm gonna do it
my internet decided not to work for 20
minutes
and then uh
and then after that i wasn't getting any
audio out of my tv
so it's just like been like a
a comedy of errors in a way and that
took like 20 minutes and i just couldn't
figure it out at all i just kind of gave
up on that one
oh my god really
don't hurt you why
okay
man it's amazing how much better the
other weapon i was using was like when i
finally came to this dungeon but i came
to this dungeon way later
all right what we got here
twin blade oh right
i forgot the twin blade was in here nice
and i think this is the last of the
wolves
yes okay
and do they give me anything uh looks
like i didn't so great
does this i wonder what this actually
gives me as is
i don't know
the one time i did use it i mixed it so
it also gave me some health and i it
gave me i think uh stamina
so or like some sort of stamina boost i
mean
all right
uh something you might have noticed too
that i did in the other dungeon was this
quick warp which i'm gonna do right now
to leave a lot faster
so a lot of the dungeons aren't like
typical from softy dungeons where these
are just
a dead ends right you just go deeper and
deeper at dead ends and you have a quick
way to get out so i guess that's one of
the things that feels a little not from
softy but i imagine the legacy and like
according to them the legacy dungeons
are where they're gonna be very very
classic from software style dungeons
so
that's where things change up it is nice
to me though like as much as people have
been like
some people not a lot but some people
have seen online complain that this is
just dark souls 4
dark souls 3
it actually frustrates me seeing people
like
call this a think this should be a dark
souls 3 expansion pack it feels very
unique to me even though mechanically
when it comes to a
when it comes to just the mechanics of
fighting it's similar to a dark souls
or bloodborne or really any of their
games outside of sekito which was the
one that was super unique
uh i mean demon souls felt like dark
souls
you know
so outside of those ones that were
specifically meant to be unique i'll
show you guys the counter that i was
talking about
that's like
that counter right there is kind of
their way to make it so you can break
guards
but anyways
the open worldness of this really does
give the game a different feel and its
own very unique feel and even though
there are
um
there are elements
that feel like souls and the legacy
dungeons and all that the open world
really does give it a very unique feel
all right so up there is going to be how
we get our map so so far i've been able
to warp as i please
but there's no map
i think is this guy the guy with the
horn
crap no no no no no no no no
ah no that's not good
all right if you just summoned everybody
then i got a book it
you know what actually this might be a
good time
let me let me equip this real fast
to show you guys a spirit ash no i don't
want that i want this
which
i have actually been trying to avoid
using but it it is worth showing it
you know
all right
so this one's a wandering mob
uh there is one that i got that i
couldn't figure out how to use
but yeah in this situation you see where
wandering mom's going to help so much
where it basically just gives these guys
other enemies to attack so i'm not on my
own
and yeah you'll definitely find a lot of
mobs in this game but um
you know it's really more of their way
to
make the open world part a little more
difficult if you choose to engage in
someone and engage with somebody
ooh what'd it be another cookbook
but yeah i'm actually gonna well i'll
unequip that spirit thing in a little
bit because i actually don't want to use
it it was just specifically because i
felt like i had to in that moment
i mean i could have gone with them
one-on-one but
you know that just takes time
all right
yeah this guy's gonna oh no oh no oh no
you a bro
well i got bros too
how about that you weren't expecting me
to have my own bros
oh
are you kidding me
i can't believe it
i had three crimson tears i just got
cocky
[Music]
but you know what i totally did it on
purpose so i could revive at this stake
america which is something else that's
worth mentioning
another choice you have is instead of
reviving at your last um
here it is there's the america statute
or state of america
another option you have when you die
is you can instead revive at the closest
stake america instead of the last place
you rested at
which
i don't think it's to make the game
easier
you know it's pretty specifically
it seems like to make it so if you
travel really really far away across the
whole map and die
you don't have to backtrack so far as
the game so much more massive in scale
in that sense
so
you know i'd really put it toward at
that
being the thing
all right
will the other guy notice me before i
can backstab you
no
cool
you know what
i'll deal with this ah man other people
attack me i was like i'll deal with him
on my own but
we got these other guys
oh
he went to town on my
friends why would you do that man why
would you do that those are my buddies
i'll let them deal with him just like in
oh i pressed r2 early
there we go
oh
oh the whole town's here now
all right i just want to take care of
that guy so wait a second
get out of here
i really honestly a lot of times just
use this as a spacer
nope
[Applause]
wait i still need to get my uh my souls
back
i don't actually don't know what they're
called in this game i've just been
calling them souls
it's like your goldenness
all right
i probably should have read what it said
that might have
helped oh wait there's a there's another
chest over here that she might as well
just get one next to it
since i've been killing all these guys
oh yeah there is another way to uh
to critical someone that i haven't been
doing which is jumping and attacking and
r2
so i guess it's worth saying that
all right what you got for me oh yeah
the riot set
this is pretty funny
just to show it
we got these sweet giant masks and i
found some npcs who had masks like that
of other
beings
which i enjoy immensely
all right let me get my horse now it's
time time to get my horse time to level
up and time to get a different weapon i
think
and go into some more dungeons
yeah i'm sorry about the
a few deaths guys i know now that i work
at gamespot even though as a youtuber
for years i'm a game journalist now so
i'm automatically i'm worse than video
games
so you know that just happens
as soon as you transfer over to that
side of working for a network all of a
sudden your skill level at video games
just like drops tenfold interestingly
enough
it happened to me it'll happen to you
too
and yeah again i'm just gonna skip her
dialogue because i'm not really going
over lore today
that was an accident i didn't mean to
skip ahead time but hey it's worth
saying that you can pass time now
okay so
what i want i'm gonna give myself some
strength i think
uh and some vigor and then eventually
i'll go with endurance i think
but yeah just nice to
feel like i'm not going to lose all that
okay next thing is we're going to get
rid of this and we're going to go ahead
and add in my
spectral steed
my
miyazaki ghost
or goat i mean
from princess mononoke
so the
you can actually dash with them which is
worth noting
um
yeah
oh wait that's right there's another
bonfire right here
and materials
also there are actually two ways to
dismount so you can switch to your
crimson tiers if you want or
whatever and not have to worry about it
so if i tap l3 that's one way to
mount or dismount or tapping square to
use the spectral steed whistle will both
mount and dismount oh this telescope i
guess i should show
where am i on this
so basically the way the telescope works
is it's a way for you to look around
from a bird's eye view
and you can zoom in and just check
things out
so
you know i imagine it's a good way to
see what things might be worth visiting
and i actually didn't notice this statue
before
i wonder if it's worth seeing what's on
top of that
because i have not yet
but yeah anyways it's a good idea and a
good way to look around and see what
sites and places might interest you but
it's something i wondered about when i
was um i did a
gameplay preview thing basically
predictions based off of hey look at
steak america america however you
pronounce it
i don't feel like fighting you right now
i want another weapon we'll i'll come
back to you later don't worry man
uh i did a predictions they're not
predictions but i guess just like
essentially like trying to see what i
could find from the gameplay preview
before i played this that they showcased
and something i'd wondered about when i
saw it on the map was what those uh
what those were so now i know
all right
basically there's a really good weapon
up there but in order to get it i'm
going to have to stop
this caravan
oh my god seriously okay
that is embarrassing
i'm just gonna start this let's play all
over again let's pretend this didn't
happen
the thing i was saying about being a
game journalist now is just it's no joke
you know i don't consider myself a
journalist but
since i've really just focused on making
it videos that i find entertaining not
necessarily like
extreme journalism
oh i like this we're battling at the
feet of the giants
oh no i accidentally tapped l3 i guess
oh yeah so if you tap l1 you do that if
you hold down r2 that's where he like
you hold down your weapon
and then you can choose to let go and
swing it whenever you choose
which actually honestly i don't do
enough so i should definitely utilize
that mechanic more
okay
no
hi
i would like to see what you have there
please
ooh piercing fang ash of war so that
little bug guy you saw that dung beetle
they have uh sometimes they'll have
hp recovers for you sometimes
mp flash recovers and other times it's
spirits of ash that you can get from
them
so that was why i just popped it back on
there to show that
all right let's do better this time
please me
what i might do actually is pop off for
the guy with the fire
okay he's not even there
all right i'm just gonna let this guy
come in fight me in the front so i can
deal with the more difficult enemy first
hey
oh apparently you can't hold r2
indefinitely i actually didn't know that
i just learned something
new i guess i've never really tried to
hold it down for that long
crap
hey
no
not no
all right
there we go got him
got him
you know actually at that point it might
have been better it made more sense just
to fight him from the ground
but
i don't always feel like fighting from
horseback is the best call
oh who shot out at me oh i didn't even
know
you were in this party
yeah maybe it's just one of those things
where it's a new mechanic for me so i
haven't quite gotten it down yet
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know blow your
horn
oh you know what i'm actually not gonna
make the same mistake as last time
[Music]
i like that it's like this little party
with flags and everything i really want
to know the lore behind this and why
there's a group or there are groups like
this
that's something i'd like to know
yeah so for killing this group i'd
imagine i should
maybe get some
health flash recoveries back
do you even have a weapon or you just
have a horn
tell me
oh i thought i'd hit him once i guess
not maybe this is the guy i hit once no
maybe none of them
the most dangerous guys of all torch men
you know i even found that in bloodborne
sometimes the guys with torches would
give me way more trouble than they
should have
all right i killed all them where's my
i didn't get anything
no
i did not mean to take that
actually uh last time i played it that
was one of the last things i got or
dungeons i went to was where i you would
have gotten on that so
that's why i
totally did not realize that was in my
inventory because i was used to tapping
three times
all right
that actually might have been the last
one
you know what
i don't need to be on my horse for this
let's just art
this two-hand
let him have a stomping fit he actually
can't really attack me i think because
he's on his chain
oh no not the guy with the steed get
away from me steve man i have no health
yeah yeah
all right
your calves
they look ready to break to me you know
what i forgot about that whole battle
was my l2 so for those of you screaming
at me to do some l2 for distance i
apologize
and i realized i could be doing it
against this guy
but what i'm trying to do is i think if
you hit him enough he actually staggers
and falls down so i just want to show
that
i say i think that's what causes it
because he did it to me and i didn't
really know the cause but i was just
assuming that was it
hey that hurt man not cool
i mean i know i'm hurting you but
and you weren't even really attacking me
i was the aggressor here
but hey i mean come on you know you're
big and scary so give me a break
okay there we go
and let's get that
bam
right in the eye hole looks like he
doesn't have eyes so specifically eye
hole
alright now
now how
i can get my weapon my goods
i think this is essentially the best
armor set in the game too but i'm just
gonna use the great sword because i
don't care too much about the armor to
be honest
but that great sword
oh yeah give me that
and what i'm gonna also do is go ahead
and level it up a little bit as well
you know what actually
might be faster for this guy though
my fat rolling
i am fat
oh you know why because i had that
equipped as well
i didn't even need it because i'm not
using double scimitars
i'm just gonna
do this guy a little bit faster
he's sad and mourning his lost friend
and here i am just murdering him anyways
as it goes as it should be
goodbye
hey i finally got some heels back
maybe that's enough heels for me to
go to pumpkin head
probably not a good idea considering but
you know what
i'm gonna do it anyways let's go to
pumpkinhead
i think it's a great idea
it's a really good really bad idea
okay so
see this right here
well
it's actually a secret entrance
to pumpkinhead my man
the last boss that i found
so also i don't remember his uh pattern
so i apologize if uh
my game plays a little rough against
them
okay
and i apologize if it turns out i should
have kept one more estus flask heal
uh oh oh i thought it was out of stamina
but i was looking at my fp bar
it's not going so bad yet
i love that his name is pumpkin head
it's great
i think that's the best part just his
name
finally the boss fight i feel okay about
what is this
goodbye pumpkinhead
it was fun but now i can wear your head
and i probably won't because i'll make
me heavy load yeah but i just want to
show it
a pumpkin for a head
kind of
oh
i didn't realize there's a side of grace
here
i wonder if i forgot to get this last
time
huh
well i'm gonna go ahead and uh give
myself some vigor some endurance some
strength which will actually raise up my
um
my equip load
so i don't have to worry about it so
much
not even though i'm just doing fine but
like you know just nice to not have to
worry about it
and look at this remember i was talking
about the fun heads we got another one
so
this is going to be our sorceress
yes i want to learn glenn's stone
sorcery even though i'm not doing that
kind of build
and the coolest looking one is this one
meteorite but i didn't get to use it
because my character did not have the
intelligence for it but anyways you can
buy some stuff from her and if you
actually do buy something she'll have a
little bit more to say
and i think now might be a good time to
go ahead and
approach the dragon i guess because you
know why not or wait actually how much
how many
of these do i have one
you know what actually i'm gonna go
ahead and get a couple of those and i'll
show you guys how
because there's actually an area that i
discovered where there's a whole bunch
of them
yeah i'll probably deal with this guy
later
he's actually he's not too bad he'll
just poison you as long as you can have
enough stuff to heal
it's fine
okay
all right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to be going uh essentially like
over in this area
so actually let's go ahead and fast
travel here because it'll be a little
faster
and there are there's a couple dungeons
that are down near that area that i'll
go to later
but i think it might be more fun to
fight the dragon at the start of the
next let's play i should have mentioned
i'm gonna be doing these in spurts of
like one hour
so
i'll be like one hour chunks
for the let's plays
to split up the three hours so this
one's got about 10 minutes left
uh but yeah i think that'll be good
and hopefully once i finish exploring
all the various dungeons
we'll see how uh the main legacy dungeon
boss goes because honestly he did give
me trouble
and it took me a while to beat him so
i i hope i do better for my own sanity
and so i feel decent about myself but
who knows we'll see how much my memory
of the patterns held up
because i was kind of just trying to
like memorize this pattern so i could
dodge everything that he would throw at
me but i don't know if that was really
the best idea
okay
i think i missed a spirit spring oh
there it is
yeah so
this gives me a chance to show this off
when you jump on a spare spring it
automatically guides you to a spot that
it wants to take you to you actually
can't go left and right really i guess a
little bit but like not much not much
okay so
over here there is
this stone thing right here
and i was trying to figure out how the
hell to get what was inside
when i discovered
the secret was these guys all along
so i think basically what you have to do
i never thought of until just now is why
not jump up and hit them in the face
anyways i think you need to have them
break it for you yeah there you go i
just saw it
god
i couldn't even get up i was trying to
roll that whole time just so you guys
are aware that whole time i was tapping
circle as soon as i fell off the steed i
guess i pissed too many of them off at
once
i'm in a fast cut got it
oh god oh god
[Music]
earlier all right
i'm i'm sick of this
this giant catastrophe i actually
haven't lost the giant once until i
started streaming or plant recording
this so
this is a trend that needs to end
all right
bro
if i may call you that
we're gonna end this thing now
i don't want to fight any more of your
kin i just want to finish you off and
move on with my life please
i got more things to do
and you're in the middle of it with that
giant butt of yours
nope
oh my god i tapped circle
why
okay what you doing i don't know that
attack
you know what i just realized i'm always
supposed to run through him and i did
exactly the opposite that's why he got
me
they always want to run through their
legs into their back
it's like giants 101 man
you can quote me on that giants 101
run through their legs
and yes he can try to swing at me
but
giants 101 giants 101 okay
point is i want to kill him to show that
they drop smithing stone shards all
right
all right and i got it so
we're done we got the sniffing stone
shard after all that frustration on my
end
i'm playing like poo poo poo
and now i'm gonna go ahead and level up
this weapon a little bit and uh
yeah i think that'll wrap up this first
episode
on that note
give me that plus one give me that plus
two
all right so
next time
i'm gonna go fight a dragon well guys
what do you say we go fight a dragon how
does that sound
my name is dave klein of dave control or
aka dave control however you want to
split it
uh this is let's play the elder ring
network test i've seen how much i can do
how much damage i can do in the last
three hours of this network test
just for
shits
giggles and what have
you and yeah just trying to see how many
of the bosses i can get to essentially
in this three hour time
span and
well we'll see you know i've didn't get
the to get to do the first network test
that some people did
but i got to do the second one and i
played a little bit
i'm personally really enjoying the game
really like uh fighting dragons
especially agile
yeah a lot of him he's definitely made
for oh he's gonna do teal splash yep i
realized as i was running in that i
should not have done that
you know what's good for him though is
that he
he kind of just takes time honestly i
don't know if i'd say he's the most
difficult boss once you figure him out
a lot of it's just realizing like
the biggest damage thing that i've found
that he does is his tail slash
and otherwise it's like if he shoots
fire which he's about to do get out of
the way
like this and then run in and smack up
his face a little bit
if you hit it which i did not
that was a little embarrassing
oh
i totally forgot about that that one
quick cut that's what quick cuts are for
oh that's right that's that
would do a little more
you know that famous saying fourth time
is a charm
rules to live by
yeah
so
one of the reasons that i decided to
fight him now as opposed to right off
the bat right when i got the horse which
i really could have done
it's not necessarily that he's difficult
it's
more that um
i didn't want to spend my entire time
just whittling away at him because i
don't do that much damage to him it's
kind of a matter of more so like i don't
know um
at least i don't know a better strategy
for attacking him
oh that went really poorly
oh always i can get a couple strikes on
him
and get away first
no no tail no no no
accidentally dismounted the horse i've
been doing that i actually have l3
sometimes
so yeah if you want to uh get him to
fall down where he can do a strong
attack on him it's all about hitting his
face
but in general it's not something i'm
focused on because when i focus on just
hitting his face
i find that i don't do as well and i
tend to just get hit by other attacks
which could just be me not being great
at mounted combat yet
hey look i just did it without hitting
his face well
right as i say that
but you can see the damage is decent but
it's not like so good that
it's something that you should really
focus on in my opinion
it's nice that it will you know do some
damage in okay he's gonna shoot some
flame down on me but i don't know where
i guess i was wrong i still don't know
his flying stuff too well oh
he actually hasn't oh i was about to see
he actually hasn't done his plane breath
for me yet which was surprising but
there it goes
yeah i've been finding if i get too
close to his face when he does that
um
it just means that no no why why did i
have to press it there by accident
if i get too close to his face when he
does this
a lot of times i'll accidentally
hit the flame breath essentially so
i've been trying to stay a little bit
further away this like just hit his neck
even though i think hitting his face
might do more damage it's just not worth
the risk
the reward ain't worth it
sometimes i find the
true philosophy of these games is to not
be
greedy and especially battles like oh
god oh god this is not gonna go well for
me
okay
you know i feel like i should just go
back to full health just in case
he's doing enough damage to me that i
just don't wanna
take the risk oh my god seriously
all of a sudden
the tide of the battle has turned so
much and so poorly for me
don't like when he gets up on these
little uh
things like that
you know if you want to do another flame
breath for me that'd be cool
nope
god again
no no no
let me get on my steam
thanks
oh god oh god i'm stuck
kill whip of course oh guess it wasn't
i know it's bad but i'm trying to bait
his flame breath to have some nice one
to go in on him with
all right now he's gonna
lash out
okay
okay flying now flying time
again i'm i'm sorry how long this
battle's taking
i like i said i just do not know
strategies to make you go faster and i
wish i did
at least that one i got to wheel on in a
little bit
just a little bit oh god okay
are you gonna do this
you know i don't actually know if it's
better to go to his left side it's kind
of just what i've been doing out of
habit when he does that
okay this will be a one attack and get
the [ __ ] out
okay yeah i figured that would be a tail
whip that's why i was like i need to get
out after that
okay ag heal
let's let's wrap this thing up this has
been long enough all right
this battle
keeps on going
it just keeps on going
that's the thing about tarnished like me
you know
it's kind of like might as well just
give up on your end because people just
keep on coming and coming and
should i be greedy
hey oh i didn't actually want to kill
him with a critical attack but
you know que sera sera quesaracera
all right thank you for the dragon heart
i'm gonna go into a dungeon now
the dragon hearts actually something
that um you can use in this network test
interestingly
for a special attack
which i'll be showing you guys later
i'll go ahead and do that but that was
one of the reasons that reasons i wanted
to attack and kill
our dragon right there
was so when i get to that area i can
just show that right away okay so what
you saw happened just there was that as
i ran in here it automatically made me
lose my speed and that's going to be the
case with all of these dungeons here
so
they do have it set up so you can't just
use them whenever i'll go ahead and go
up and grab what you just saw i'm sure
in a moment i just want to
rest here
not die and get mad at myself
by rolling at the wrong time
get some level ups in
uh wow this really isn't raising my
strength up as much as
i thought it would
maybe if i level it up one more time
it'll be a little better in that regard
also did i get anything from my i think
yeah okay so this is the mixing of the
wondrous physique you might have seen me
pick up that crimson crystal tear last
episode restore a half of total hp in a
mixed physique so i'll use that and then
the other one is temporarily boost
stamina and mixed physique
causes concoction explode i don't
totally understand i actually haven't
tried it yet so maybe i should
but uh okay so now as you can see this
will actually do a little bit better for
me
and let's see where to roll off i think
it's gonna be right there
yep there we go
i don't actually remember what the item
is that we get here but throwing daggers
okay
you know actually i think for this boss
i might switch out to my other weapon
now that i think about it
and might give myself one more fp
because he does not like the fp attack
if he's down here
and i'm just gonna be a little bit
smarter in how i play this time
so let's do that actually
okay
because now i have another way to heal
anyways so
i'm gonna give myself one fp
because that's gonna be good for the
boss down here oh
unable to acquire a summoning pool due
to inventory of storage max
no
i haven't seen that yet that's why i
wanted to pick it up i had no idea what
that was
so
these guys are really strong against
attacks or physical
just so you guys are aware i guess i
could show you and i'm going to show you
guys actually when i get to one
down here
but let's see how much this dungeon
oh god i forgot about the rats
the rats aren't really the issue is that
last time i came down here i got
attacked from behind and kind of got
ganked
by someone who's way more powerful this
guy yeah this guy came at me
and that was what i kind of surprised me
last time i came down here all just for
a smoldering butterfly
and ain't nobody care about that
all right popper's runes cool
uh let's see where's the other one
yeah so those guys can't be backstabbed
who have the packs on their back which
is the interesting note about them
all right and then
this one actually i think if i remember
correctly if you go to the bottom it's
actually going to be a dead end so this
one you actually have to roll off of to
finish the dungeon
which is pretty cool
so it starts to feel a little more from
softy this dungeon so i like that they
included this one just for that reason
because it starts to be like oh you have
to be more clever about how you explore
the dungeon here
all right let's take care of you
pufferoo
there's going to be one more paparoo oh
gravitas is there gravitas is a pretty
cool one i actually thought i got it
from
the boss i'll try to show off some of
these ashes of war ii at some point
sometimes i forget about jumping
oh boo
uh i could go back here i think it's
just a dead end yeah it's just this
stuff so
yeah i don't want to get trapped there
with him
and yeah it's just that stuff back there
so i think all the only point of going
down here was for that gravitas
all right let's do this
and i think facing this way is the roll
off yep there it is all right up steak
and marika there america however you
pronounce
it and
so we're getting close to the boss
here
yeah this guy just likes using his lamp
for fire
hey you don't don't do that please
hey actually you know damage isn't too
bad against them with this one with this
weapon last time i was here i used a
different weapon
wow actually i can't believe it i'm
actually like stunning locking him
this weapon is way better for these guys
damn
what was i doing being afraid
i gotta go back and redo this whole
thing
oh i didn't even know that there was a
smithing stone shard there that's nice i
wonder if these guys have them
that'd be interesting
do you have a smithing stone shard no
do you have a smithing stone shard
oh my god
it's so much better i mean it's not
surprising that they're easier when you
can actually stun lock but
you know that's like abcs man
one two
three i want smithing stones even though
it looks like i'm just going to be
getting glenstone scraps
why is this package all glowy
it just looks like embers are in it i
guess so you can see that's actually
cool
all right so i'm just gonna show off
this here
just because it's kind of fun
um
i don't know why i pushed that down
there but check this out
don't worry guys
it is a from software game and if you
fall you will die
so
there still is enough fall damage that
you die but they've still got classic
from soft uh traversals like this
french folk runes by the way um they
essentially act as souls that you can
take to quickly get
experience runes are your version of
souls in this game
that's the name of it it's runes okay
all right this is not gonna go well
this is really not gonna go well because
i have no healing
but hey you know it is what it is at
least i can uh use my crimson
my cerulean tears
all right ready for boss because i ain't
i sure am not ready at least there's a
steak america right by
hello stone digger troll hello
okay that
was dumb
yeah he's got like a giant range with
his stuff
which is really why i wanted to be able
to heal oh also
i'm uh targeting the wrong thing if you
actually manage to hit his face that
will stun him
at least it did for me the one time i
like really nailed it and got him right
in the face
and then he was trying to block his face
from getting hit again which is pretty
cool
oh god
nope no no
no
oh
that was a one-hit kill all right
all right i see how it is
don't follow me don't hit me bro
is there anything on this side so i know
i always like to do the classic from
soft thing of when you go to a boss pop
that back up there to make it easier for
yourself to go back up just do yourself
a favor
all right here we go
oh sh i pressed the wrong button
because i'm a [ __ ]
oh look see
that's what i was talking about
so yeah just like fun detail
and look now he's trying to block his
face from getting hit i love it it's
like it's so cool
well now i'm just gonna bust your
kneecap open
dog
oh [ __ ]
no oh no no no no
i thought that was going to be a one-hit
kill to be honest
yeah that went great you know that went
really good i was i'm happy with that
oh my god
there we go
no it actually does a decent amount of
damage when you do that to him too
all right
you know i guess i could just spam l2 oh
okay i can't spam l2 for this moment
that was dumb
wasting my attacks
i'm stuck oh my god i got stuck i got
stuck i got stuck oh you're kidding me
[ __ ]
all right
all i have to do is one hit or two
no
one hit
ah okay
hey dragons complete oh right that's
what you get from him i can't use it
because you need faith
um
there is a faith requirement for it
which i could level up a little bit just
to show it
uh see
unable to do this effectively with
present attributes because you need
faith it's
i actually don't know if strength works
the same way as previous games we didn't
actually technically need the strength
i guess i could show off this a little
bit though
this sweet twin blade which is actually
pretty badass in my opinion
uh yeah and again now that i've finished
the dungeon i can just quickly get right
back to the top i'm just exploring a
little bit before i do
okay
let's go back to the entrance
thank you thank you very much
one giant out of the way
oh i gotta go back to the bomb no thanks
so there's going to be actually a spot
right there
with um
with uh
sight of grace so maybe i'll head that
way cited grace time
and actually i'm going to go ahead and
quit back on my
hordovis greatsword eventually i will go
ahead and fight that guy right up there
i've honestly had some trouble with them
which is why i'm being a little more
cautious about it
if i'm being
honest um but i will fight him at some
point i'm sure there are some people who
fight him right away so i'm sorry i'm
being a little more cautious
uh
again i just don't want to keep on like
banging my head up against the wall
essentially
just with the limited time that's
actually what i like about these games
is mastering things and i don't mind
that at all
but within the limited time frame
uh
i feel like you know
i'd rather show more things essentially
i'm gonna go this way so i don't take
fall damage
you know to be honest i don't even
remember if there's really anything
interesting back this way
like there's stuff that looks cool but i
don't know if i actually found anything
get out of here bat
get get
get
although it would be nice if i could get
my sword to plus three just saying
that'd be pretty uh it'd be pretty tight
all right where is the sight of grace
now it's somewhere around here i think
it's up top there it is wait no
you actually see glowing around them
to kind of help you find them and
indicate where they are
gotcha
poison bloom sick
uh huh oh actually i think it is close
to here i think it's gonna be on the
other side of this
hey
it's this guy i didn't know he hung out
here he actually helps you uh during an
npc fight
or like he'll come and like help you
co-op essentially an invader
that's sick
you must be the new tarnished
beautiful work
failing that dragon
and as such
there's something you might like to know
the heart you brought back
it's used in drug and communion
if you should find yourself overcome by
hunger for the heart
yearning for its strength
then seek the decrepit church
on the little island off the western
coast
why i just might you must not forget
though
those who partake in dragon communion
will one day shed their humanity their
hunger for dragon
they're yearning
only worsens
until the floodgates burst
unleashing eternal torment
the strength of a mighty dragon
magnificent
but deadly it's no surprise that dragon
communion
is ruinous
you must not forget though
those who partake in drug and compare
hunger until they flip the strength of a
mighty there's no
wow that's sick
like i i did not find him before it's
cool i'm still finding things that
i had no idea we're here i'm sure
there's a lot of things i've missed
honestly
and i don't really have time to fully
explore a lot of the mechanics too
so
yeah that's all really cool to me
okay
so let's decide where to go at this
point
i think what i'm going to do
is again i don't remember there being
anything interesting down in this area i
know there's that big flower i could go
kill there but there's a dungeon up
there i think i'm gonna go hit that up
and then there's a dungeon in this area
that i'm gonna go to that actually takes
you to this runes here that he was just
talking about where i can use that
dragon heart i got for being a dungeon
so i'm gonna see if i can do all that
stuff this episode and there's one other
boss i'd like to value to
if i have time so that's what i'm gonna
see
if i can get to uh yeah hopefully i can
hit all that
so
that's that's uh my goals
you have the camp of these [ __ ]
oh damn nice
wow i can't believe how much damage i do
against them now that's sick
you see what he's doing there that's
actually uh something that you can use
with a ash of war too
all right
and let's go into his camp of his bros
nope i was actually trying to get out of
there but that did not work for me
i think there's a sleeping one over
there yeah
i'm gonna lead you out of here so i can
attack the sleeping one without waking
him up oh my god all the wolves
get out of here wolves get out of here
i know i didn't play as the bro whose
name is like wolf man but
okay okay okay
this is getting stupid now
all right fine
you wanna you wanna battle
let's battle
on the ground
sorry for not parrying guys i'm sorry
i just wanted to deal with him i know i
know
all right let's go ahead and do some
sneak king stuff here i'm playing burger
king now
eldon ring burger king edition
all right that did not work out at all
that's okay i guess
ooh the bloody wolf set sick so you can
actually find every single set
in the game that you can start with in
the network test just laying around
places so
uh i mean some of them are laying around
some of them you have to purchase but
it's just like a nice touch that you can
actually find them all
i don't know if this is gonna be the
final item placement for the final game
you know there's really no way for me to
know that but um
yeah it's just a nice touch like i said
all right i think there's a
sight of grace up here actually
so i'm gonna go for that
give me your sweet juices
oh this is what i want to check out nice
okay
like i said um
there was one of these that i didn't get
to use last time
and it should do exactly what i thought
nice yeah it shows exactly where that
site is
i think there's a like i said i think
there's a
side of grace around here so i'm gonna
look for that
first before i hop down there
where is it
it's pretty damn sure oh
whoa i didn't explore this in the past
that's interesting i don't remember
exploring this at all oh
well that would be why
yeah you know maybe there's a reason for
it i still think that there's a sight of
grace around here though
there is there definitely is it might be
up
no it's by the drop-off or spy age
drop-off
could be up here though so i'm gonna
check up on top of this one
because if i don't find it's just gonna
drive me crazy but
uh
yeah it's like ultimately it's not a big
deal i just
like to find it for the sake of being
like yes my memory is correct
all right
you know there's golden glowies around
it so
i don't really have much excuse for not
finding it but
yeah it's not going to be up there
let's definitely buy this but where
where
and i remember falling into a pit of
skeletons when i dropped down from it
so
if i can figure out where that pit of
skeletons was
it was basically like directly above it
all right this skeletons ain't here
oh here we go
ha ha i was right all right
yes
and then that means i can yeah because i
think i was like dropping down here and
i was getting hurt because i didn't
realize
that the thing that was in the uh the
alden ring preview that they showed the
gameplay preview was up there so this
will actually be my first time going
down those gravestones
but if you do drop down from right there
you actually take a decent amount of
fall damage
so it's definitely smarter to do it from
up here you know it's cool that that
actually shows up on the map too with an
arrow i didn't know that
all right so
let's go ahead and properly drop down
oh you can even jump across
what is that thing oh dragonfly okay
all right that's fine i'm not as
interesting
okay
let's go here next
and
i think that's gonna be as far as i can
drop
well then
let me call my steed
i don't know if it helps with fall
damage but sometimes i try to like
double jump
as i'm dropping down all right sick
now i feel like the fall that they did
was different in the
the demo or i mean whatever the gameplay
preview
i don't even remember which boss was
here to be honest
but hey
it's gonna be a good time no matter what
all right there's gonna be a bunch of
these guys i do remember that actually
this was one of the first dungeons i
actually found
so that's why i'm kind of like trying to
memorize it and be like oh what was
it i love that design so much with the
heads i mean i know i fought that guy
already but
it's just such a cool design oh
okay
i'm curious about this specifically
because i didn't have a chance to use it
when i tried using it it always showed
this
see that line through it so i'm actually
curious to see if it works against the
boss so i will be using it on this boss
but
bear with me please i hope you
understand why all right see those guys
i'm gonna do this where i try to
get them to come out so i can yeah trick
them up like that
unfortunately i only got one of them
but you know one's better than none
right here let's see if this hurts the
other one
hey nice
i love using the game's traps against
the enemy it's so satisfying when you
pull it off
but you know this is a good indicator
again that there's gonna be traps in the
dungeons you know what i actually
haven't found that was in the demo
though was uh there's like a no [ __ ]
there's a dungeon that had an illusory
wall
and like a big swinging blade
and either that doesn't exist in this
demo or i just didn't find it so
um which i'm sad about because that was
so cool it just reminds me of king's
field and i love king's field so much so
anything that reminds me of kingsfield
it's like a huge perk to me
unfortunately the fire for this is gonna
be actually on the other side
so i can't use the fire for this
specific guy right here for these two
but that guy might have might have
worked yes
i'm gonna use this because i always
forget it exists
so this is a good dungeon one for me
yeah i think the fire comes from that
side if i remember correctly
for this specific dungeon
all right
wow there are a lot of signs here or
whatever messages here
all right again let's see if the
northern mercenary ashes works just
because i didn't have a chance to use it
before
oh it's this guy yeah see i don't know
how to use him
like maybe i can only use him in the
legacy dungeon boss i i just really
don't know
i'm super curious about it though
oh he gets staggered huh
no no
all right
very good
it doesn't always get staggered that's
interesting
only sometimes
it's gonna be really hard to uh to
predict oh you know what i think i did
against him last time i found him as i
used my distance attack a little bit
more
so
not that it matters but yeah i think
like when he just does this it always
scares me a little bit
yeah i think that probably gives them
more attack i would assume i think
that's what that does
and it looks scary more importantly
it's all about the scary look should be
real
there we go nice backstab
backstab boys are here
goodbye grave warden
it was fun though it was fun i had a
good time i hope you did
oh stormblade sick
so stormblade
if i remember correctly is the ash of
war that
the wolf class starts with in this game
sadly i think that's it though but we do
see this sweet design here i mean like
who wouldn't want to party with this guy
right am i right oh you know what i can
do now too actually is uh get the pvp
guy to invade me so
maybe i'll go ahead and do that
okay
let's see
level up
i could go with faith just to show you
guys that that item i mean it's not
going to do much for me though it's kind
of a stupid choice
i like the idea of getting my endurance
up uh actually i didn't realize
endurance raised your uh
your defense huh yeah i mean with
endurance that'll make me happy happier
oh you know
never mind i was gonna say like you know
i'm so close might as well just level up
or use my my items
time to show you guys the
guy helping me with the invasion so
that's what's up
next no i i'm realizing something i
probably should have mentioned before
doing this let's play
was that i talk a lot
that's just kind of my style i guess i
feel like if you're going to watch
someone who doesn't talk might as well
watch a long play
in my
estimation otherwise
to me a less play is where you watch
people talk and either joke about things
or explain things or whatever
yeah so it actually is forcing me off of
my steed so i don't know if that's how
all invasions work because i haven't
been invaded yet
but that's how i know this one works
i actually did do some pvp on my own
invading people but
i think there's better people than me
for showing off that sort of thing
it's funny when i first got invaded by
this guy i actually thought that it was
a real invader at first i well i wasn't
sure i should say
all right
are we gonna we gonna do this bro
hey i actually did pretty well against
him
oh i was like do i even need euro
this is actually going pretty oh god
well
i still can't summon that guy when can i
summon him i actually have no idea
nope
so see euro over there is the guy who
we're talking to about the fact that i
killed a dragon
no euro do not take my kill
jura you almost took my kill and that
was not cool
hey he actually said something before to
me this time he didn't maybe it's
because i got the kill
i think if europa gets the kill he
actually says something
a cerulean crystal tear
did i have that before
is this
new whoa restores 20 percent of total fp
in mixed physique i wonder if you only
get that if you get the kill because
last time i didn't
so that's interesting i guess if you
don't get the kill on him
you don't get that
so definitely interesting to me
so if i keep going this is going to take
us back to where the dragon was
again for the sake of time
i'm going to go ahead and move on
actually i think this is pretty cool up
there
but you know i guess i'll go down here
first and get to this area just because
it's a little closer so let's go back to
the church of kale
kale
kale bloomfress bloomfest
doing some girl the dragon tattoo
references here
i'll take some vigor thanks actually
that was dumb it didn't give me much
help overall
uh you know what i'm curious about let's
see how many how i'm doing in terms of
uh
this stuff okay i only have three
yeah
i don't know where i got all my last
time
i i definitely was not grinding giants
i mean look i killed all the bosses with
plus two except for i actually went back
and killed the tutorial boss because i
hadn't
and one shot at him which was pretty fun
but
you know
it would be nice
for that the boss here because i really
do struggle with them
if i'm being totally honest
the big bad and the legacy dungeon
which yeah i tried there are two
entrances you can take in the legacy
dungeon and both of them resulted in
dead ends or multiple dead ends
uh something i should show here actually
just because it'll be cool
before i go into the dungeon is this
over here
i finally realized what's going on here
which was that
like these spirit tracks are pretty cool
but it's actually like some really fast
invisible enemy
so if i double jump oh missed him okay
the one time i actually killed it
was i did like a double jump
and i guess i just happened to hit it at
the right exact right spot
i don't know how
big this guy is i don't know yeah i just
don't know
but yeah i might as well try to get him
no
damn it
i'm gonna end up wasting all of my time
just doing this just watch me just watch
me
no okay
oh that felt like it was the right spot
it really did it really did
maybe i should be using my lighter
weapon so i can swing it faster i really
do think i just use this weapon though
now
the son of a [ __ ] is too fast for me
man
okay not there
i'm sorry about this
i'm sorry i just wanted now
there we go i guess he wasn't in there
oh he's just rolling on the ground so
the fact that i was jumping was making
it worse
all right ash award determination
and we'll go to this guy i'm gonna go
ahead and sneak up on him
oh i guess you can't backstab them
from there that's what i was trying to
get
here poison thanks
wow you can cure poison amazing
and you know i'll fight off the octopus
guy there's also an npc down here i'll
show and then we're gonna go into a
dungeon
oh yeah
yeah these octopus guys are awesome i
mean they're not octopus i guess they're
turtles that are corrupted with
tentacles i don't know why i keep
calling them octopuses
and by i don't know why i mean it's
because it's awesome
i just
nope
excuse me
let me hit you in the face please there
we go
yes that's what i wanted
and now we'll kind of like obliterate
your tentacles
you don't need those right
no you did not okay cool
so yeah that's those are those guys
there you go and let's see here
next up
on this tour
yeah that's just from room fragments all
around there
there's a cave around here somewhere but
mainly
it's probably to the left right there
yep there it is
first thing we're going to do is find
ourselves an npc he's just another
merchant
uh he doesn't have too much to say
either
but the main thing is that he sells the
um
swordsman set which is what i started
with he sells the champion set and he
also sells the profit set so quite a lot
he also sells some uh a cookbook i'll
buy the wait no i don't want the
cookbook i don't care
i take it back i don't care i'd rather
use that for uh
for levels you know i'm gonna be smart
no
look see i still have figured out i used
those northern mercenary ashes
again though maybe the legacy dungeon
boss i'll try it there i really don't
want to beat him with ashes
i'd rather get the satisfaction of doing
without any ashes which is what i did
when i played it on my own
but i still like to uh
you know out of curiosity just find out
if that's how i use it
and also get some footage of it because
i'm curious i'd like some footage you
know
that'd be nice it'd be very nice for me
all right let's turn on the summoning
pool even though uh it
doesn't do anything
and then this is the boss that i i had
some trouble with but
hopefully this time i'll do a little bit
better so we'll see
wish me luck thank you
okay this time it's going a little bit
better i think
because i'm i didn't have this weapon
last time i fought him
and i think like this just does such so
much damage
it's like eating him a lot oh god i'm
gonna die anyways aren't i
that would've been sad yeah the really
the issue with this boss isn't
necessarily the boss itself it's that's
a gang fight uh so it's really just the
amount of enemies in here with you
that make this boss challenging
but yeah if him himself
not so bad
the gank aspect of it kind of bad so
there you go hey you guys come here
please don't wake up the i woke up he
woke up
that's okay
yeah i know
oh okay i just want to roar a little bit
cool
wow like remember when i was talking
about how it was kind of hard for me all
right
that went just fine
again though i i really was just because
of the ganking and this weapon is kind
of op against them let's be real i mean
you guys saw that i'm being honest here
that was a pretty opie weapon
against this bro
nope no wow this weapon's just kicking
some ass in this cave
hot damn
son of sam i'm just showing you guys the
rest of the cave
i don't think there's anything
interesting here there's just some
enemies up there
hiding in the dark
at least i can get the club you know
but yeah this is actually a really cool
cave to me because it actually ends up
leading to another spot
so that's pretty sick when i first
popped out of here i was like whoa
i didn't know this was gonna lead
anywhere
so that was just a really cool
experience
to realize it actually led to something
and it was also the only way to reach
the thing that it led to as well i don't
think there's any items i missed
last time i played because if you notice
when i beat that boss it looked like i
didn't actually get anything for beating
him
but this is the final enemies in here
who i've given up because i've killed
their boss
yeah so i could warp away return to the
entrance or just keep on going which is
what we're going to do
and yeah it's the left here it's gonna
be an enemy i believe oh there he is
oh okay oh wait oh just one i need two
more come on two more give me two more
network test oh god i accidentally
switched to shield bash only
i thought i was just tapping r1 for l1 i
mean to dot
to uh not dodge to hold up my shield
just in case
but i guess at some point i accidentally
tap triangle
and we emerge out on the other side
so cool there you can see uh where we
just were
and yeah i i really like this aspect
that they actually connected some of the
areas in this manner
you know i still haven't gone to the
base of an earth tree and i'm so curious
i think what's there is uh
things for your
your uh what is it called
where is it
there i think it's for your wondrous
physique flask and it has to do tears
maybe that's how you can upgrade your
flasks
hey can i level up again
level up again no oh man all right
so because i got the dragon heart if you
recall now i'm at the church of the
dragon communion which we'd heard about
before
and
uh if i go to the altar which i believe
is this
perform dragon communion you get gray uh
grails roar
so that was because i had and i'll show
you guys it for defeating the dragon the
dragon heart game power the dragon at
the draeneic and communion altar which
is where i just was
and that's going to go ahead and give me
grails roar there sound the roar of
great action dragon grail
so yeah cool stuff
cool stuff
all right guys thank you so much for
watching and that's been about an hour
so
uh we'll see how much i can do in the
next episode but my plan is there's a
boss right there i'm gonna go fight
against
uh
maybe try to beat the guy down here and
i think that's then this boss i think
that's it i think that's all the bosses
if i'm not mistaken but now i'm at the
real tough uh stuff so we'll see how it
goes the final hour
is upon us
one more hour
in this network test
so let's do it i got the uh the true
rough bosses now in front of me
so
oh i wanted to check
how many of these i have four
okay four all right okay
there are a couple ways you can do this
and go about this area right here
i'm just gonna go with a straight on
charge through
um you can actually go up and around
which is where i was at earlier with the
giants
so
yeah you don't really have to go through
this part you have some options here
and
again i'm just rushing through
so i can try to
do as many bosses as humanly possible
within this run
uh okay so
you know i'm gonna go ahead and
get the side of grace first just so i
don't have to run through there again in
case i goof up somehow
yeah so cytograce is up here
these wolves aren't a fan of it
i don't know if you guys know this but
wolves hate sights and graces they're
like enemies mortals sworn enemies of
sights of graces
the scavenger shack i think this is all
that's there is the litany of proper
death
which actually i don't know what that
does i i'm sure i looked at it at one
point
litany improper death
produces an arc of gold that deals holy
damage
sick i really do wish i like played with
the build where i could test out some of
this stuff because a lot of the attacks
sound awesome
it looks like they really went all out
and the sorceries and spells and faith
in this game
so i really do wish i could have seen
more of that
all right
but anyways we're gonna run back down
this way
because there is a boss down here and
also there's some stuff to the top right
that's kind of interesting which i might
try to quickly run at and glance at
but
yeah and again i'm sure there's like a
bunch of stuff i'm missing i i wish i
had more time to do this let's play but
the other time was three a.m for me and
i was like i'm not i'm not i'm just not
i'm not
uh okay actually
uh you know i could just go up here
since i'm already over here actually
i meant to do this second but that's
okay
these jellyfish guys are kind of awesome
in my opinion
i actually really like jellyfish
i think they're really cool as long as i
don't fall into a swarm of them
i'm okay with jellyfish
so there's gonna be a couple of red ones
here which means they don't like you
and if you attack them then the rest of
them don't like you
guarding whatever this is that i can't
remember
oh oh that's right it was jellyfish
spirit cool
yeah before i was attacking them and
beating them with ranged attacks but
uh i actually haven't really tried melee
against them they shoot stuff at you
from the distance that's their way of
attacking
so there's actually no uh sight of grace
over here that i found
but there is going to be um
one of those statues america
right there that you can see
and i have no idea what these guys doing
why they have glowy eyes but so if i
fail against this boss that's where i
get to restart at
and yeah it's interesting this is
forlorn hound evergowl
so this is something totally different
so i don't know how this is gonna work
in the game or if it's just like a quick
boss fight sort of thing
i really have no clue
uh i have a lot of runes held i guess i
gotta be cautious that if i die
to go get more
one
two and three and hit
and okay one
i thought he's gonna do his jump against
me
nope
crap two and
three
nope
and three
and
okay fine jerk
dodge
dodge two
one
two and three and
crap crap and crap
all right
one
two and three and hit and jump and
attack and hit
i goofed that crap up
one
two and three
i shouldn't have gone for that but i
really wanted it
i don't have enough
hp to be messing with that sort of thing
honestly
there we go
lucky i had another one of these
okay
come at me bro
one
two and three
yeah it's like this guy's pattern is
pretty simple oh crap
so
yeah when i played before i kind of
memorized it as you could tell so
yeah that made it pretty easy oh you
know what's interesting i just noticed
my my uh
beacon that i set was still here so this
was almost like just an alternate
version of the exact same thing
because that beacon is still like seats
in that exact same spot
so that's interesting it was still there
so i wonder what that this area kind of
means
anyways let's go back to the scavenger
shack shall we
and to the point where i start to get
nervous because we're going to be
getting to the uh
hell bosses
by my estimation
all right
great
great
this is where it's gonna get real rough
uh between
uh the guy who's up here and um
well
the guy in the studio i chose not to
fight i actually i haven't tried killing
him on my horse i i was doing it off
horse and maybe that would help
give me your ash please
thank you
actually i think there was one up top by
the
by that guy oh i just realized something
i missed that i could go do two oops i
forgot about that
all right
i'm gonna go here and what i'm actually
gonna do first
is i'm gonna go ahead and finish uh
i'm gonna try to beat the other guy
first and i'll take this guy on last
kind of just makes sense to me that way
especially since i honestly probably
have a better chance with this guy so i
can fight more bosses
all right
here we go this is where this is where
it's gonna get real rough but we'll see
we'll see what happens
okay
well wish me the best please
thank you
all right nope nope
where are you crap i was
targeting the wrong guy
yeah i know i know i didn't have to be
doing that
crap
this is not going well for me already
let's be real
all right
i'm gonna quick cut through this stuff
so you can we'll see how long this takes
me
oh that was not cool
nope
wow that really screwed me up actually
the targeting on him
went the complete wrong way yeah i heard
him for so much more when i jump and
actually hit him though off on his horse
and it makes sense
nope
he's going to do this dumb horse jump
attack now that hurts for a ton
so basically i just need to like go on
his
oh oh
no no are you kidding me
no
what was that
i guess i should have stayed horseback
that's lesson learned i guess
oh my god
why is this switching the targeting on
me what was that
wow this fight is like totally different
horseback i'm glad i have footage of
where i didn't feed him horseback but
like
um
because that knife both just to show it
but yeah this is definitely easier
horseback
way easier horseback i know i died a few
times but
uh once i figured it out i guess that's
what a lot of the stuff is right once
you figure it out
that's that's all it is it makes all the
difference in the world
all right this is the point where i
honestly wish i had more
more of my stones for leveling up
i mean i know i could go get them and go
fight the giants but that feels cheap
and lame and takes extra time
although i actually it might help me a
lot wait
max equip load
yeah you know what screw it let's get
some more damage all right and i'm going
to go
hmm
i just want some more of those things
can i buy any of them from the merchant
i doubt it but i'm gonna check
it'd be nice it'd be nice
i don't know 45 minutes is enough to
beat this boss
wait
nomadic person cool
more importantly do you have you do not
have them
you are awful i don't know why we're
friends in fact we aren't friends
no screw it it's time it's time i'm i'm
doing it i'm gonna pop some
[Music]
some uh
[Music]
some stuff here
items
nope don't want to craft i want to use
this
so i can level up one final time even
though i might not have enough still
let's see
no
i don't have enough
i'm gonna have to go kill some of these
guys i think
i mean i know i have a few of the small
ones but
even then i don't think that's enough or
it's
or i'd be feel wasteful maybe
all right wow these guys don't give much
yeah they get a little bit okay they get
a little bit
check this out
yo you got to attack me so i can do my
check this out thing
oh what the oh my god
you ass ruining everything that i wanted
to set up
here now i can do it
there
that's all i wanted to show was that so
much to ask for
i don't think so
you can destroy that for no souls i mean
runes
same difference
okay
here we go let's use one of them
and i definitely have enough now i can
remember it was 2700 2800
level up um i'm gonna go with endurance
to get my defense up a little bit
yeah
and
and
okay something i didn't show before was
this set and i'm gonna go ahead and put
it on now for this guy although if it
makes me heavy i'm gonna switch my
helmet
or the crucible set which is what this
weapon actually goes with
because i'm gonna just i'm gonna go uh
max health that i can go with i'm also
gonna see if the
northern mercenary ashes works with this
guy
i'm not gonna show his cutscene because
again you can watch it and i want to see
give myself the most number of chances
okay you can't use it so that's cool
one two three oh i actually do decent
amount of damage against them
you know if i leveled up to plus three
it'd be sane
insane
you know what's funny i always it was
always the exact same spot that i seem
to lose against him
nope
all right margaret's what a weird name
you're gonna do your fast one i bet yep
that's that's what i think it was this
fast one
nope no no oh my god i'm so stupid i
took my hand off of the controller for
one second and of course he did that to
me
okay hammer time
one and
boom
now i gotta get out of there
bam okay i should have attacked him but
i got nervous to be honest
no
i had all of my healing stuff left all
of it
in the second half i just had not gotten
down anyways i'm gonna quick cut it
nobody likes you
nobody notice i talk to everybody
everybody in the world
not interestingly not a single person
likes you margaret
no no
oh my god that is actually kind of close
margaret you're you're a piece of crap i
hate you so much
yo margaret
yo margaret listen up
i got some bad news for you
i talked to every single person
everybody and nobody likes you
nobody i know it's sad
so
you gotta you gotta just give up here i
think you know
because see the thing is the fact that
you keep on doing this it's like
it's not helping the fact that nobody
likes you i'm just saying i'm just
saying
nope
god damn it
um
those hurts so bad
and not being
in the right position for that hurts bad
too great
not screw i'm gonna get up in his face
and it didn't work
who needs to play smart when you can
play dumb am i right
[Music]
i seriously can't believe i got on this
low but i'm sure my luck's run out at
this point
really
yeah yeah hammer down bro
i got greedy and i thought it was going
to be a bad idea but somehow
somehow it worked with zero flasks
oh my god i can't believe i beat him i
can't believe it
it's successful three hours i've been so
afraid for these full three hours that i
was gonna like put up a crappy showing
ah
oh elgin ring oh
well now i can uh show this part i guess
a little bit
so that was a
racing of the heart a little bit okay
what do i want oh i can level up twice
that's pretty sick
debating about that or endurance i kind
of want some more endurance actually
i feel a little op right now but
that's okay yeah i definitely was not
this high of a level last time i
finished him
man did i beat all the bosses
i don't think i missed anybody other
than the tutorial boss but you know
that's okay
so let's get to the end of this demo
then
so there are a bunch of things i'm going
to skip through here just for the sake
of uh
just for the sake of that i'm trying to
get to everything and show all the big
enemy bosses
but
um yeah so like there's there's some
areas around here you can go down around
for some items
again that i just don't feel like i have
as much time as i'd like to show
but at least i can get to one of the
dead ends of the demo or the network
test
and then um
yeah then i'll get to another one
there's actually a decent amount of
sights of grace here but
oh i can still
interesting i could still use that there
once you're inside the castle at the
very least you can't use the map anymore
so i'm not sure exactly where it cuts
off
so to the left there is going to be an
item you can go down and grab
which i sorry i'm not going to do again
i want to try to
show off more of the test i just almost
fell off
a map here
okay
let's see if i can sneak by this guy
this time
and by this time i mean when i played
the first time i was not able to he blew
his horn on me and alerted everybody
so
that was a little better at least i mean
they saw me but it's not as bad as
when i played on my own
so there's a guy up there um
he'll see you and shoot at you pretty
much no matter what but i'm gonna get
this item anyways
there you go
these guys are the guy who i was just
talking to the gatekeeper
so you know up to you if you want to
trust them or not didn't expect message
says the person who left the message
what
hi
he's he's not too bad you could try to
sneak and kill him but yeah he's not too
bad
i wonder if the resin is what gives my
weapons more power this time around
i wonder
oh yeah this stuff's gonna blow the hell
up if i let them hit me
and
no
so what i'm gonna do here is let him
blow those up for me
classic demon souls you know
and once i fight the guy up here then
i'll do a little bit more of the
exploring down here wait
oh i was like what's that ghost is
does that mean there's like a special
thing
yeah see there's that right there that i
was talking about
which i will get after i beat this guy
here
i was trying to figure out there's a way
to get down there but i couldn't figure
it out
oh i don't think i oh i was about to say
i don't think i got that item but
apparently there's a reason for it
because you can't
all right
uh last time i went to this guy i had
zero health so this should hopefully go
a little bit better
oh oh so what it was trying to do is
show a cutscene there where
basically it closed the door on me
if you guys are curious
oh
thank you
no
i don't know what that thing is at the
bottom that he's trying to do to me
actually
all i know is it's almost there and
that's not good i'm sure
oh i thought that was gonna hit me
no
what
no
okay
okay
i thought i was dead
you guys get away i got a boss to run
and try to
get back to again after i goofed up last
time
whoa
nope
okay he likes to scream a whole lot
doesn't he
you quit your screaming you quit it
nobody wants to hear it
nobody
what are you so afraid of
you're the one who has like freaky 5 000
arms because of godric or whatever
it's you
it's you as the freaky arms
thank you for your rusty key i'm gonna
go get the arsenal charm
and my uh my room's back thank you
so the arsenal charm
raises max equipment wait wait wait very
nice thank you thank you for that i
appreciate it
yeah i don't think there's anything here
liar ahead oh i bet someone put my uh
you know that there is an illusory wall
man i'm sure there's an illusion while
somewhere in this demo i missed which is
really sad to me
because i just didn't feel like i had
time to swing at every single wall
unfortunately
i got a degree in wall checking
and uh i feel like i failed
my degree
maybe i need to go return it
sadly
all right popper rune
thank you and then we'll go up here and
get uh
whatever this one is
oh oh one smithing stone shard i guess i
need one more
all right check it out
sadness ahead are you ready
more weights to an official release no
no
no truly the saddest of times the
saddest timeline
uh okay so that's
wraps up that spot
wait a second
i just realized hey i missed a uh
another map segment that i could use
so
or i mean uh side of grace
let's go use another one
yeah i'm trying to rack my brain to
think if like there's any bosses that i
missed
with this
20 minutes that i have left
but again i just don't think there is
can i level up again no
no sadness
but now i can show you guys what's
beyond those gates which i'm sure those
of you who have not watched a million
other
less plays that i've been posting at
this time might be wondering
i want to use the main entrance thank
you
and purchase uh
none of this stuff
so
this is going to be for faith the claw
mark seal and finger seal
uh the sorcerer's staff is obviously for
sorceries and then
he sells
two faith related things i believe
those were
all right
gods open the gates
for me to go get slam-dunked possibly
thank you thank you
by the way it's not like specifically
like a left side thing i don't think
what the
oh my god that was not cool
okay
i'm out of i'm out of i'm out of stamina
i'm just trying to go use this i'm just
trying to go use this
all right
i don't know why there's one right here
but i guess that's nice the gate side
chamber
and uh
so that should be all of the sites of
grace except for the beginning one
and there's not really anything up here
i guess i could jump up there i didn't
know that but
yeah okay
there is gonna be another big bad enemy
though and i'll go ahead and go for him
also i tried using this
and i could not so
unless there's some way i don't know to
it just wasn't something you could do
unfortunately
by the way up there there's not really
much of anything which is why i'm
running to this side
because over here there is something
that i want to show you guys
which i find to be much more interesting
which is this enemy right up here who
we're gonna go ahead and
duke it out with
oh no oh no come on another enemy coming
at me
oh good this guy hurts them that's nice
i actually didn't know that
oh crap i'm getting yeah i was actually
getting hurt by the other guy more
he's throwing me off
crap
you know what i've actually so nothing
happens in here by the way i'm just
wondering if i can lure him here so we
can have our own arena
nope
oh wow i haven't seen that attack before
that's interesting
i was like i'm gonna just go for it
screw it i bet i can knock him out
and i was right
yeah so i've tried hitting this nothing
but i did want to show that enemy
because it's like i guess an away
another one the big bads and once you
kill him he doesn't revive and come back
so let's go back to the gate side
chamber because i'm gonna i'm out of all
my heals
and i'll go ahead and level up and then
go to the top dead end
so let's do that
and level up
my endurance sure
no usually i like to play more uh
deck space builds but i've definitely
been doing more of a
strength base build
obviously
with this guy
just because i like the weapon so much
all right you
gone get out of here okay now i wish i
leveled up my uh
my weapon just so i could kill these
guys in one hit that'd be nice
one running swing hey that was one hit
cool
well anyways
uh you know oh wow that was not good
all right [ __ ]
basically i'm gonna try to go around
this way so i can sneak behind
and you guys will see why
come up if you're gonna fight me don't
just stay there throwing things at me
okay don't want to fight me fine
yeah these actually i'm noticing these
trina lilies do seem pretty rare and i
think that's like their description is
that they're supposed to be rare
interesting you can just sneak past
these guys like this
so that's cool
and this part's gonna get a little
brutal
because these guys like to toss fire
bombs and then there's gonna be another
one of those archer guys up there
and it's really the archer guy who's
like they just do so much damage
um but yeah i'm gonna try to yeah
there's the archer guy
crap
mainly though i just want to get up here
to show you guys what's up here so again
it's another gate and then you get that
ash of war for war stop and that's it
and so that is the other dead end here
uh to show you guys if i try to access
the map
while i'm over here
well
at least i mean it could be because i'm
on combat but i've had times where i
tried to access it where i felt like i
wasn't in combat and i was not allowed
to right now i'm pressing the buttons
and nothing's happening
oh wow that was
not good not good
so yeah i guess that's like that's the
main stuff i want to show i'm actually
honestly i didn't know if i'd be able to
do this in the three hours
so i'm i'm really happy that i was
that's
the main thing i'm just super stoked
that i was actually able to get through
all of this in the three hour time
so
yeah bosses i i had a little bit of a
rough start for sure
but
yeah you know overall actually i think
this went all right so that's cool
these guys got their barricade up
yeah oh you know what i should have done
while i wasn't in battle was try to use
the map again just to show what happens
all right that's that's uh
that was a stupid move on my part
no no no
nice
okay so i think that's all them oh i am
able to use the map huh all right i
learned something new
well let's go down here actually wait
wait wait let's go to the first boss
actually let's let's just
conquer all the bosses am i right
tutorial boss
he's got to go down now just so i can
feel like i got them all i collected
them all all the pokemon
i'm actually pretty excited i actually
have the opportunity to do this
so now i can show you guys the tutorial
ha ha how about that oh wait you know i
don't want to use this i'm going to
switch to some a different stuff
let's do carry a knight
let's do
swordman
let's do actually i like i like the
swordman stuff actually i think it's
pretty cool the cloth fast
no actually
i think i can do better how is the night
armor ah that's pretty sick
ah it's okay
i take it back i just think it's okay
hmm that's fine let's do it
i can't waste too much time on the
fashion souls i gotta i got a final boss
to fight
this is the real true final boss of the
demo if you can beat this boss then you
are an elden ring
master
i don't know if you guys know this but
you can guard in the game
trying to teach you guys how to play the
game now
but yeah my main takeaway from playing
this is that
i i didn't get to play enough of the
legacy dungeons to see how much they
felt like souls there were definitely
some mobs it does have a different feel
from souls in my opinion
uh the way the design works the mounted
enemies there are
it does make it feel different
so
the open world and again the fact that
it seems like a lot of the emphasis is
on doing the dodge strong attack or
dodge i mean the guard strong attack
gets some emphasis
so it does give it a different feel for
sure and how some of the exploration is
but
it's different enough that i i enjoy the
differences because you know i have
souls and i'm happy for what it is
i have demon souls unhappy for what it
is
and i feel like this does feel unique in
its own right there's another stake of
marika
and let's see uh if we can take out this
boss i don't know soldier godric
a little terrified but
we're gonna we're gonna see we're gonna
see
oh crap
oh no
i'm all right
there we go
can i get an amen
i don't know why i said that all right i
think that's all of them so cool i'm
gonna do some exploration and uh explore
down here because i didn't really do it
and maybe i shall go fight the flower
thing too
because you know something i talked
about and i actually have time to go try
to
take it out so
that's nice
maybe i'll start with the flower guy
actually do i have one that's closer i
do
let's do the flower guy
and then i'll explore
so all right
flower time
and yeah i think i really do think
that that's uh
that's all the big bads in a sense with
that guy
okay
he does have his poison that he likes to
spew
but i'm not so worried about it because
yeah i'll get poisoned but
i can heal so it's okay
you know
that's okay
all right so flowers taken care of so
that shows that oh there were smithing
stone shards there are you kidding
oh my god and i can't
even
warp to use them because
oh wait i got immunizing meat so maybe i
can
boost immunity oh that doesn't matter i
thought maybe would uh
cure me in my poison
wait do i have any items that i can
no
maybe i don't know yeah i can't wait i
can't use the map i didn't think i could
okay we got it we got to level up to
plus three we got to do it now
i got it i got it we got to do it
so i guess that's where i found some of
them in the past i just didn't realize
that's where the location was
oh hell yeah son
oh hell yeah
i kind of wish i had that for the
tutorial boss now but that's okay
all right let's do some exploration
so something i was trying to do in the
past well while i was playing this
the first time was see if i could
wait a second
is that the one i just was at
i didn't realize it was so next to the
sea for whatever reason
anyways
uh i was trying to see if there's a way
to get down here but all of them all the
ways i tried were insta-deaths
which i guess i can show you guys that
there is indeed fall damage
so
at least i can show that off now
so it's not like you can just drop down
anywhere
um outside of instant deaths if you are
high enough you also get fall damage and
there's a stat that you can use that
lessens your fall damage
although to be honest i'm not
remembering which stat it was at the
moment
um so one of that does affect fall
damage specifically
and
yeah i don't know let's see what else is
around here
so this is kind of just a dead end with
some enemies that i've found in the past
unfortunately
because yeah i felt like there should be
something down here because it's
a dead end area but really there wasn't
i guess all that's here is whatever this
is which is some proper rooms
i mean maybe it's just because the
world's cut off from what i'm allowed to
explore and there is something
interesting here normally
i guess it wouldn't matter as much when
you have the whole world it's like just
another
dead end
but something i will say is it does feel
very handcrafted the
full giant world design which is nice
um
i mean
there are open world games that do and
there's ones that feel less so much as
like this one feels like it has a lot of
intention i guess i should say
obviously unless it's
essentially a uh
ai generated
unless that's the case someone's
handcrafting it but it feels like
there's a lot of intention
behind it the map and where things are
laid out in this which is
a huge positive
so yeah you actually can't explore down
here i wanted to check what this was i
imagine it's going to be similar to this
it's probably another ever go all
because it looks similar and i might be
pronouncing that wrong
but there's a lot of area down there
that you actually can't look at which is
part of why
um yeah i just think i don't don't think
i found anything down there when i was
exploring on my own
i wonder if this guy's here still or if
he went away
yeah maybe he goes away after he helps
you
because i didn't see him just there
uh typically on top of these things i've
been finding rune fragments
so i'm sure that's going to be the case
on top here oh hey
ah okay
what's that i'm actually really curious
now
i don't even know if i looked for that
oh oh i just remember something else i
can do
that i can show
nope i almost forgot i almost forgot
that there's a fall
trina's arrows okay
all right so i'm gonna go here and fight
a guy on a bridge
that sounds like fun right
i don't know if he only appears at night
i was trying to look up if there were
things i missed and this is how i found
out about this guy but he there's also a
guy who's roaming here during the day i
just don't know if it's different during
the night because it was made out like
it was
i haven't noticed any differences that
are only night or day but it's also
because i haven't explored enough to
really find that sort of stuff with
those very specific differences
uh so that really that could be why and
their tree looks so cool lit up like
that it's lit son
so yeah like if you notice i was
crossing before and there was a guy here
before but
it might be a different version
because i don't know if he had that cool
reaper axe thing before
he does some damage
no no no
oh bro
bro
bro
he died he actually died
uh okay well i am the reigning champ
that battle did not go as i was hoping
it would
i wonder if he revives though let's find
out he probably does but now i'm curious
bruh
what the hell man
okay let's let's try that again shall we
yeah okay you know cool battle
that's how i want to end my elton ring
experience i feel like that really
symbolizes it honestly that's the first
suicide i've seen so that's pretty funny
battle suicide i've had people knock me
off to my death but not that
so let's try it again
i mean i guess if he's not there that'll
be kind of cool to feel like oh it was
more special in a way even though he
died and i didn't get anything since he
fell
yeah he's not there huh
what do you know
i i hope there wasn't some cool item
that i missed that i'm not able to show
i feel like i should have really shown
more spirit ash stuff and all that so
and again i never figured out how to use
that guy oh
oh okay the other ones there's because i
didn't buy them i think the other ones
are buy ones but i can show you guys
jellyfish at least
okay i guess i can't
that's interesting
what if it's a time of day thing for
when you can summon these guys that'd be
interesting
why huh
i don't even know why some of them are
blacked out right now like the jellyfish
one
i guess it's just another mechanic that
you have to learn
yeah why can't i use my jellyfish that's
weird
huh
weird
i have much to learn
i have much much to learn i wish i could
play this game more
uh okay you know i have two minutes left
so i'm just going to talk about my
overall experiences and roam around boy
you there
could you help us out kelly
who's talking to me where is he
you
yeah you there
stop pretending you can't see me
what the hell
where's the guy
is he invisible
why won't anyone look me in the eye
i'm i'm not that ugly am i what
i wonder if i can find him just by
hitting
oh my god like another mystery thing
where is he
this is so interesting
maybe that's where the signs are signs
are like gonna indicate where he is
mimic korea's head therefore try
attacking
oh
what'd you go and do that for
what
oh yes
i remember
some clod turned me into a tree
you were just breaking the spell weren't
you
thank you
the name's bach
i was pushed out of the cave
told not to come back
not ever
then i ended up as a tree
lucky you came along really
oh i'm almost over with my network test
this sucks i want to see what he has to
say when they threw me out of the cave
they took everything i owned
and so this is all i have to express my
thanks why do you have some expressions
you can forgive me he's on a network
test
a glowstone
very cool well if you can afford to wait
for a while actually i could sneak back
into the cave and bring back something
of actual value well then i'd be of some
real use to you i reckon
right
but i'll need a moment oh man i wish i
did this at the beginning the test i'm
frightened of them
so i have to gather myself
my knees start knocking just thinking
about that
oh okay she already killed the bosses
there
i wonder if that helps at all
oh man oh man no i need more time
oh my god i can't believe i just found
something new
i'm sure he's talking about the dragon
pass cave then but i already killed the
boss guys there
so i'm just gonna warp here okay
uh dissenters cave and then maybe work
back and see if he's there
or maybe if i turn it like today time or
something or night time again maybe if i
pass time
oh man i like it's like 10 01 right now
so i have no idea when network test is
just gonna end on me
okay let's a little full day pass now
he's had time uh yeah yeah yeah okay
okay okay
come on come on come on come on
i don't really even remember exactly
where it was either it's just like to
the left there somewhere
like by these trees
is he gonna be over here again
he's not over there okay
maybe he's over here maybe if i go in
there and i run to where the bosses are
or were
oh god oh god the test is almost over no
i mean technically i'm past time
so we'll see how much extra they're nice
enough to give people
all right
all right any anybody here anybody here
is he here
uh
uh
i don't see him unless he's too small
all right yeah i have no idea
all right i'm gonna go ahead and warp
back
i'll try to switch it to like daytime or
something
and see if like that does anything but
again i kind of talked a little bit
about my overall experiences but i
really do enjoy the game a lot and i
like it for its differences it's the
same thing with securo even though in a
way that was more different
but i
like i love souls
i really love the souls games so i'm
happy to have anything more that feels
like souls from from software they're
absolutely been one of my favorite
companies since kingsfield
as some of you may know
and
i'm just really happy to see another
game from them and i think it's
really well done so far it's different
but very well done so
i am enjoying that about it and why is
this guy just been dead this whole time
tail
that's interesting he just was laying oh
i guess he was just sleeping
oh man the guy's gone i don't unless
he's outside the cave which he could
have been
oh my gosh i i i can see comments not
being like he was right there you missed
him no
but i just i don't know where to look i
don't know where to look
this is the last spot i can think of to
try i'm sure he's somewhere around here
if you see him again
i'm sure
but yeah i just i don't know where it
would be
other than somewhere around here
i mean i feel like this is the cave he
was talking about
oh well so anyways yeah thank you guys
so much for joining me it's been a lot
of fun playing i hope you guys had fun
watching
and
as i said this was going to be three
hours so
uh i guess i could keep just roaming
around and seeing what other random
things happen
i don't want you again i don't want any
trouble neither do i bro neither do i
so
like that was cool i wasn't expecting a
random thing i had no idea exists there
i thought i was actually looking for the
guy from the
gameplay preview
who reminds me of sigmar a little bit
who you like is basically a giant pot
that you bash
i was expecting that sort of thing
so this is actually pretty cool right
here
you see where you would fall off i doubt
you can jump across but i also haven't
tried
um but yeah it just doesn't look like it
so i don't think it's worth the try
uh but right here is a double jump one
so if i jump off of this it's actually
going to guide me right to another one
that i can then jump off of an ike did
not know it could guide me there to be
honest
because that didn't happen to me in the
past
all right let me try this
again i need to go this way please thank
you and another one
and i think it kind of forces you this
way actually
like i don't think you can choose to go
to the right side unfortunately
but
maybe i'm wrong maybe that's something
some other guy figured out that i did
not
uh
open world dark souls man it is truly a
treat
and yeah hopefully
when the game comes out for real you
know i'll be able to talk about the lore
and death
uh i'll have a lot more planned for you
guys and prepared i'm actually haven't
looked over all the item descriptions
yet in depth i uh
i recapture them all all the ones i've
found at least so i can start writing
about them
so that's like going to be one of my
plans here for myself
i'm going back down to this cave to see
if i can try to leap across the
waterfall and just see what happens
because you know what why not
why not
oh
i thought that was gonna be death for a
second
i i'm sure this is gonna be death but
hey i'm gonna check it out
you know i could have also right there
jump down to that bottom one there and
that might have been cool
all right
well here's to death no
haha
that was worth it
totally worth a shot to see what
happened
i just i really like that i've been
able to find another thing
i want more time with this so i can
explore more i'm so jealous of the
people who got this early and i know i'm
lucky getting this when not everyone got
to but
man they have had like another 15 hours
with this game would have been so cool
it's also amazing how much um i
personally i improved
playing this game the first few hours i
guess
i played for three hours and i started
again with a different build so i kind
of replayed the same stuff
um
and just like comparing that to plane
now even though i was messing up a bunch
i still feel like i definitely improved
and uh
i imagine next time i play i'll
done this so again which is the great
thing about these games is they give you
that sense of personal improvement
and the souls games are just so good at
they're so good at that
wow that was not what i was going for at
all
remember when i was able to ah all right
yeah
uh-huh uh-huh yes
this is what i wanted
i feel like this is the perfect time to
leave a message
inventory
i haven't written a message yet so
no no okay
well
i got an extra eight minutes so thank
you powers that be bandai namco from
software
uh so yeah
guys i had a ton of fun with this thank
you so much for watching i'm just
excited that i was able to show you so
much of it and get through so much the
demo i wish i'd be able to show you
sorceries and other things but
uh and yeah i hope you guys will join me
for the full game i'll be covering the
game on gamespot
but um
yeah
again i can't wait for february where we
can talk more elton ring and to hear
your guys thoughts
and yeah i'll see you guys later later
guys peace